ein pfingstausflug bei strahlendem
sonnenschein endet für 14 menschen mit
dem tod
kurz vor der bergstation riss die gondel
am monte mutter ohne plötzlich in die
tiefe
prallt wahrscheinlich ungebremst gegen
die stütze und rutschte den abhang
herunter
nur ein fünfjähriger junge aus israel
überlebt seine urgroßeltern seine eltern
und sein kleiner bruder sterben trauer
auch um ein junges paar aus italien
der kleine urlaubsort stresa am lago
maggiore steht unter schock in das
totengedenken mischt sich die wut über
die verantwortlichen
es gab in letzter zeit einige meldungen
über probleme die die anlage gehabt
haben könnte
wenn man die verschiedenen ursachen hört
ist man noch geschockt leider sind das
dinge die man vermeiden könnte es ist
ein wunderschöner ort es ist eine sehr
schöne fahrt aber sie sind ja alle
hungrig nach geld die drei beschuldigten
sind mittlerweile wieder auf freiem fuß
der seilbahn chef und ein ingenieur
weisen jede schuld von sich
der techniker gabriele tarquini hat
gestanden die notbremsen zuletzt
mehrfach deaktiviert zu haben weil die
bahn sonst hätte geschlossen werden
müssen
es tut mir sehr leid an der unglücks ban
ist das zugseil gerissen warum ist noch
unklar
in jedem fall hätte dann die notbremse
greifen müssen die die gondel auf dem
noch intakten tragseil festhält
doch die notbremse war am unglückstag
mit einer roten kabel blockiert genau
diese rote kabel fand die ermittler in
den trümmern
offenbar wurde die notbremse außer kraft
gesetzt der grund sie soll den laufenden
betrieb gestört haben
professor gabor oplatka ist einer der
wenigen unabhängigen experten für
seilbahntechnik forschte viele jahre an
der hochschule zürich das eine gondel
mit blockierter notbremse fährt hat er
noch nie erlebt
ich habe keine worte um das zu können
weil das ist außerhalb meines
vorstellungsvermögens ich bin bestürzt
und bin empört und und habe null
verständnis damit weil die bremsen
blockiert war
sind 14 menschen gestorben der schweizer
michael meier hat jahrelang selbst in
der seilbahnbranche gearbeitet bis heute
sind bahnen und ihre technik seine
leidenschaft auch die seilbahn von
stresa hat er mehrfach gefilmt als er
von dem absturz erfährt geht er sein
archiv noch einmal durch er kann kaum
fassen was er da entdeckt für den laien
kaum zu erkennen der technikfreak ist
sich sicher
mir ist aufgefallen dass man auf diesen
fotos die diese socket ohne wie sie in
den italienischen medien breitgetreten
werden schon zu sehen sind also schon im
jahr 2014 wurden diese vockert ohne mit
personen in der kabine eingesetzt die
focke tone die gabel die die notbremse
blockieren das sei bei leerfahrten in
ausnahmefällen erlaubt sagt ein anwalt
der beschuldigten für wartungsarbeiten
ist das praktisch ansonsten aber
kriminell und meyers bilder aus dem jahr
2014 zeigen auch fahrgäste in kabinen
bei denen die notbremse offenbar
manipuliert war
die kabine 3 das ist auch diejenige die
die abgestürzte sehen sie hier am laufen
und hinzu und ihre charakteristisch
diese diese beiden diese beiden kleinen
spitzen das ist diese für gewindestangen
die gewindestangen mit denen die gabeln
befestigt waren sind auch bei der
absturz gondel zu sehen
auch dieser aufnahmen hat michael meier
in stresa gedreht deutlich zu erkennen
die roten gabeln die die notbremsen
blockieren
auch meier ist mit der gondel gefahren
am 9 juni
2018 der hauptverdächtige behauptet die
gabeln erst vor kurzem seit april 2021
eingesetzt zu haben angeblich als
notlösung diese version wackelt wir
zeigen professor oplatka meyers videos
das deute darauf hin dass man das
möglicherweise früher auch schon gemacht
hat offensichtlich hat man das
praktiziert und bis jetzt glück gehört
auch der italienischen
staatsanwaltschaft liegen die videos von
michael maja jetzt vor
die ermittlungen laufen wir treffen
claudio zanetti
er war vor 20 jahren verantwortlich für
die seilbahn am lago maggiore
wir zeigen ihnen die videos die lange
nach seiner zeit als seilbahn chef
entstanden sind
ausgedrückt wird das ein beunruhigendes
richtung die vergangenen jahre
das hieße nämlich dass dieses vorgehen
präsentiert wurde
mit dem das hochsensible
sicherheitssystem der seilbahn
ausgeschaltet worden ist weil man
glaubte dass das sei niemals weisen dass
sein nachfolger davon nichts gewusst
haben will und ein einzelner techniker
verantwortlich sein soll hält sein motiv
für unrealistisch es ist schwer
vorstellbar dass die mitarbeiter eines
so kleinen unternehmens ist die seilbahn
gesellschaft von mutter ohne ist nichts
gewusst haben wollen
über so eine eklatante tatsache wie die
deaktivierung des notbremssystem michael
meier den hobby filmer lässt das unglück
nicht los er fragt sich ob der absturz
hätte verhindert werden können wenn die
behörden den einsatz der gabeln früher
bemerkt hätten
nach einer langen corona pause war der
betrieb erst kurz vor dem unglück wieder
gestartet 14 menschen sind tot weil das
geschäft trotz defekter bremsen
weitergehen sollte
[Musik]